All right.
With that, we're about
three minutes past 7:00.
So I think I'm going
to get started.
Thank you, everyone, for coming.
I'm Shannon Rose McAuliffe.
And I'm the manager of
the Student Arts Programs
here at MIT.
We're very pleased to hear from
this really fantastic panel
of students and faculty
involved in the Arts at MIT.
Joining us, we have Justin
Park from SyncopAsian,
Ryan Kim and Junhee Li
from the Logarhythms,
and MTA Professor Ian Hattwick.
Thank you all for being here.
Tonight, this group is
going to share with us a bit
about their experiences
with playing and recording
virtual music
during the pandemic.
And then, we'll have some time
for questions and comments.
And before we get
underway, quick
disclaimer that this
event is being recorded
and may be made
publicly available
on the Arts on the Radar website
or elsewhere in the future.
If you do not wish to
appear on the recording,
please make sure that
your video and audio
are muted during the event.
And please contact us at
Arts on the Radar at MIT
dot edu if you've got any
questions or concerns.
And with that, I'm going to
turn it over to the Logarhythms.
Hello.
My name is Junhee.
I'm the President
of the MIT Logs.
We're an a capella
group on campus.
We have been around
for 70 years.
This is our 71st or 72nd
year performing, I think.
So we're a pretty old group.
And by nature of a capella,
primarily what we do is sing.
So in a normal year,
that would mean
that we spend around
six hours a week
separated into three two-hour
rehearsals rehearsing music.
So that, of course,
in general requires
a lot of physical connection.
We're all in the
same studio singing
to each other reactively,
adjusting volume, pitch,
so on, and so forth.
And as you can expect, a lot
of the music making in general
is very collaborative
and in person.
So when we were sent
home last semester,
there was a big
transition period
during which we
were figuring out
how we would proceed with
the rest of the semester.
Fortunately for us, we had
a lot of time to think.
But also, we had a
lot of stuff kind
of taken care of beforehand.
So we were in a
situation where we
had a lot of
arrangements figured out.
We were in a situation
where everything
that we had planned
for this semester
was pretty much already done.
And it was just a
matter of finding a way
to perform it somehow.
So that made the transition
process much easier.
But, ultimately,
what we ended up
doing is we had a weekly
Zoom meeting during which,
most of the time, we
actually didn't rehearse.
Most of the time, it was
actually just social.
But simultaneously,
there was a lot
of time spent going over
old arrangements, sometimes
new arrangements, annotating and
thinking about what we wanted
to sound like, how we
should sing our parts,
and also listening
to the music we
were supposed to be learning.
So kind of the
individual processes
that we would normally do
to prepare for a rehearsal,
we just kind of did
it together on Zoom.
And that was kind of how we
replaced in-person auditory
rehearsals.
And then, simultaneously,
we had a lot
of music prepared that
we wanted to share.
So we really, really wanted
to find a way to present that.
So our primary inspiration
was through a bunch
of other musicians who've
already been doing this even
without the pandemic.
For instance, Eric Whittaker
had a concert, a virtual choir
concert, that was
very, very popular.
Had a lot of singers.
And also artists
like Jacob Collier
have done lots and lots of
collaborative videos, merged
videos and audio.
And so, we thought it
would be a good idea
to produce videos that
were produced separately,
recorded audio and video in
remote distant locations,
and then combined and produced
into one final product.
And then we also had an
idea to queue our videos,
stockpile them, and
then release them
all in kind of a concert style
at the end of the semester.
So that was the framework for
how our semester went down.
Overall, we had a pretty
productive semester.
The amount of music
learning that we did
and the amount of music
making that we did
was actually not very different
from what we would normally
do in a semester.
So I think that what we did
was a pretty good replacement,
at least for our
way of functioning.
And also the Twitch stream
at the end of the semester
was also surprisingly
more successful
than we thought it would be.
And it was a lot of fun to
get to kind of watch that
come together and see
the audience enjoying it.
Although there is, of course, no
auditory or in-person reaction.
But it was cool
to see that there
were a lot of people
watching, giving comments,
and stuff like that.
As for the more
technical aspects
of what we did
over the semester,
I'm going to hand
that over to Ryan.
Ryan was our, Ryan is
our event coordinator.
And he was in charge
of most of the concert
that we produced at the
end of last semester.
So yeah.
I'll turn it over to Ryan.
And he can talk more about that.
Yeah.
Thanks, Junhee.
Great to be here with you all.
So, as Junhee said, we did some
remote a capella production
this past semester
because we weren't
able to be physically
on campus together.
We found a way to remotely
record different tracks
and combine them into kind
of a cohesive a capella
product, which included
both audio and video.
And one of the things
I think is really
cool about our
production is that it
was entirely self-contained.
We didn't hire anyone to do
any audio editing or video
editing for us.
And a lot of us didn't know
that much about this beforehand.
But we were able to learn
throughout the pandemic
and eventually create
something that we're
pretty proud of at the end.
So I guess first of all,
how this actually ended up
going down is we start
with an arrangement, which
is the center of an
a capella production.
And an arrangement
is basically where
we, an arrangement is basically
where someone writes down
all the notes that
everyone is going
to sing, including vocal
percussion, beatboxing,
and just all the
different rhythms,
all the different syllables
that people are going to sing.
The solo.
All the harmonies.
And we have that all down on
a couple of sheets of paper.
And we send that out
to everyone normally.
And what we do in
this remote time
is we transformed that paper
sheet into a digital file.
And then we sent
that out to everyone.
So a digital audio file,
which contained basically
how we envisioned
the song being sung.
And then everyone
listened to that recording
and then recorded themselves
singing their part.
So looking at the sheet music
and listening to the reference
track, they would
record their part.
And everyone would upload it
to a central Google Drive file.
Then the person who's
mixing the audio, so mixing
is a term just in
audio production
meaning just to combine all
the different audio tracks
and make sure all the
volume levels are right,
apply different
effects, do things
like modify the frequencies to
make the sounds a little bit
different.
And I guess I'll
show a little bit
about what that mixing
process looked like.
I'm going to share
my screen right now.
But basically, if you look here,
here is one of our projects.
I think this was actually
our most involved project.
But we have, so everyone
filmed two tracks.
A left track and a right track.
Because that creates
a greater sense
of space for the listener.
And then, we would combine
all these tracks the other
in the different voice parts.
And then we did
some timing issues
because, in person,
it's easy to get
a sense of where everyone is.
Sometimes if someone
rushes at one part,
the whole group is able to
kind of compensate for that.
But because we're
recording remotely,
it's harder to anticipate
how others are going to sing.
And sometimes there's a
need for timing correction
or also pitch correction.
But we did all of
that within this file.
And then we also recorded
some extra parts.
For example, there's
a clapping section
towards the end of the song.
And I actually just recorded
myself clapping 10 times
into my microphone right here.
So you can see it on
the screen right here.
Just a bunch of
recordings of me clapping
at slightly different times.
And it creates the illusion
that there's a chorus clapping.
But yeah.
We were able to combine
all these different tracks
and apply certain effects.
Some examples of
effects are reverb,
which creates a sense that
you're in a larger concert
hall or something,
because there are
different copies
of the sound coming
at later times or
different reverberations.
There's an effect
called EQ, which
is where you modify the
different frequencies that
are within a sound file.
And you can emphasize
certain parts
of the sound to create
a really different feel.
And yeah.
That was about it
for the recording.
And then we had everyone also
recorded videos alongside.
And we combined those
videos together.
And I think I'm going to
screen share real quick what
that ended up looking like.
[SINGING]
Is the audio playing?
OK.
[MUSIC - PARAMORE,
"AIN'T IT FUN?"]
What are you gonna do when the
world don't orbit around you?
So what are you gonna do when
the world don't orbit around
you?
Ain't it fun livin'
in the real world?
Ain't it good seein' all alone?
Ain't it fun?
You might be the one
who's running things.
Well, you can make
anybody's [INAUDIBLE]
and get what you want.
See, it's easy to ignore trouble
when you're living in a bubble.
So what are you gonna do
when the world orbit--
So yeah.
That was what our final
product ended up looking like.
We ended up having, I think,
seven, six or seven songs
that we created
for the semester.
And we streamed it on Twitch.
And it ended up being
pretty successful.
We were pretty happy
with how it turned out.
So I think that's
about all I have.
Thank you for having us.
And I'll turn it over
to the next group.
Perfect.
Thank you so much.
That was really exciting.
And next, I'm going to invite
Justin from SyncopAsian
to get up on the
figurative stage.
Let's go.
Hello, everyone.
Thank you for having me.
So yeah.
As I've have been introduced,
my name is Justin.
I'm a third year
undergraduate at MIT.
And I'm here on behalf of the
a capella group SyncopAsian.
So we are, of course, in
a very similar situation
to Logs and to all the other
a capella groups on campus
in that, this past
semester, we've
been unable to perform
a concert live.
And so, we're struggling
with what should we
do in terms of producing
music over the semester
and also over the
following summer.
So we decided to take
a similar approach.
And we considered
putting together
some recording projects.
And so, we had a
number of arrangements
which we were considering.
One of the biggest problems, as
has been touched on by Junhee
and by Ryan, is the
difficulty of rehearsing
in a super efficient
way while virtual.
So we decided to focus our
efforts mostly on the recording
aspect of it.
And so, we looked
at the list of songs
that we have already performed
and haven't gotten around
to recording yet or ones
that we've been working on
but haven't been able
to fully bring to life
because we all got booted
off campus and such.
So yeah.
So we decided to
take that approach.
We recorded all our
audio and video virtually
and pieced that
together from home,
had a number of people
working on that.
So just to share some
details of how that worked.
I personally was on the
production committee,
so to speak, for Synco
this past semester.
And I, in particular,
handled the audio editing
for our projects
that we put together.
So what that entailed is
a lot of the same as what
Ryan showed earlier.
So it involved the mixing.
It involved retrieving
everyone's audio files,
balancing them properly, doing
pitch and timing corrections.
So one of the quick
learnings I had from that
is, one, is that I have a
newfound respect for people who
do it professionally, having
to do that all myself,
realizing that
there's a lot that
can go into making
something really sound good
and really come through
as a powerful mix
that you might hear on a
professional recording.
But it was also a
really cool experience.
Because I had almost no
knowledge about this going in.
And so, just learning how
to do this from scratch,
fiddling around
with the software,
fiddling around with things
I could find on Google.
And if anything,
it's a testament
to just diving in and trying it.
Tossing things together.
Mixing it.
Key takeaway, I think,
for me is that there
is a lot more than just tossing
everything together and trying
to line every up
so it sounds good.
Ryan showed earlier a
lot of the work that
goes into balancing things
and making sure that pitch
and timings all match up.
There's also a lot you can do
just with individual tracks.
The number of softwares, even
something free like Audacity,
you can do things such
as noise removals.
You can compress
your audio tracks.
You can change the EQ so you
can make certain tracks open up
a little more, make them
sound a little less muffled,
boost the bass if you are
on track that requires
a bit more of that,
whether it's a vocal bass
or vocal percussion.
And so, just getting a
sense of how that works,
balancing those properly,
so that every track really
comes through it the way you
want it to in the final mix.
I think it's something that
there's no fixed handbook to.
And it's something that
you really get just
by fiddling around with it.
I think it's the
biggest takeaway.
Developing just trial and
error, just figuring out what
works the best.
I don't want to dive too much
into the technical details
of how I did the audio mixing.
On the video end, we
actually had a lot of fun
with this video for this
one project in particular.
Because, let me share my screen.
Is it visible to everyone?
Yeah.
So we had a lot of fun with
this one particular project.
So this is something that
we had performed last fall.
And so, we performed
it at our concert.
And we were planning
on recording
the song in a studio for
it to get professionally
mixed and such.
But we didn't get around to
doing that because we all
had to leave campus.
And so, we considered, well,
this is a nice hype song.
Anyone who's familiar
with K Pop is
likely to know the song
because SyncopAsian,
being the East Asian interest
a capella group on campus,
one of the big genres we
sing is this sort of K Pop.
And so, we thought, OK this song
by BTS, it's a nice hype song.
So we decided to record it.
But we thought, how could
we kind of make this,
give it our own little twist?
And we saw all
sorts of a capella
covers going around making
the rounds on Facebook
with different groups all over
the country, around the world.
And a Zoom themed cover
seemed to be fairly common.
So we really decided to kind
of hone in on that idea.
Just like people from the
Logs mentioned earlier,
everyone just
recorded themselves
singing along with their
video and sent it over
to our video editor, Daniel
Lu, for this project.
And we kind of went
with the Zoom theme.
So we added a lot of these
little quirks across the board.
Kind of just this little
chat feature, the Zoom tiles.
[KPOP SINGING]
Insider secret.
The reason we had the
videos flicker on one
by one at the start is because
some people's videos started
later than we would have liked.
So, hide the error with
a staggered entrance.
Looks cool though.
And it looks very Zoomy.
Yeah.
Make with it what
you can, I suppose.
Yeah.
So we had a lot of
fun on this project
because there were
a lot of things
that we could do with
regards to giving
the these little quirks
that people who use
Zoom are very familiar with.
For example, if I can
skip forward a bit--
[KPOP SINGING]
I've waited all my life.
[SINGING IN KOREAN]
My internet's not fantastic.
[KPOP MUSIC]
All right.
It looks like we're having a
bit of an internet connection
difficulty with Justin.
Are you back?
Yep.
I'm back.
Sorry, my internet is--
All right.
Excellent.
Potentially a little
questionable right now.
Please don't worry.
We've got about
two more minutes.
So if you want to wrap it
up, that would be great.
That was really excellent video.
Yeah.
Sure.
So yeah.
One thing I didn't
quite get to show off
there, which I won't make
an attempt right now.
Just because my internet
might die again.
We did little things where
we added some quirks.
There's a second soloist.
So when they switched over,
they raised their hand over Zoom
to start soloing.
We added little Zoom emojis
when the vocal percussion
did fancy things.
And so, this was really nice
because it was also really
a cool collaborative effort.
Even though one person was
spearheading the video editing,
there was something
a lot of people
could give feedback on in
designing the storyboard,
so to speak, for
the whole video.
Deciding what little features
we could add in, where
transitions should happen.
And so, this was a
really cool way for us
to still be able to
work collaboratively
on a project that wasn't
just people recording,
sending it to people
to do all the work.
Even past that, people could
still contribute their ideas.
Find ways to give their
feedback on the way
the audio is coming along, on
what we could do for the video.
We had a number of
iterations of both the audio,
where we sent it to
the group and made
sure everyone was
really on the same page
with where this
project was going.
And so, yeah.
I think overall I'd say that
doing this sort of recording
project, we put together
some other recordings,
as well, over this
semester and the summer.
This is, I think, the
biggest one we did,
the one I just showed you.
But these sorts of
project, I think,
were a really cool way to stay
connected over the semester
and over the summer, to keep
producing music together,
to really feel like everyone's
getting involved in this
and really still
contributing to the group
and to what we like to do.
Make music for the community.
So yeah.
It's been an awesome experience.
And we're definitely
going to continue
recording and producing
things this semester.
Excellent.
Thank you so much.
If you want, we
would love for you
to share some of the
other recording projects
that you've done.
Probably in the chat
would be the best.
But we can also
take those via email
and send them out
to people, as well.
All right.
And with that, we're going to
go to our last presentation.
And that is Professor
Ian Hattwick.
Take it away.
Hi.
So I'm Ian Hattwick.
I'm a Professor at MIT in the
Music Technology Department
in Music and Theater Arts.
And I'm also the
Director of Family, which
is that MIT laptop ensemble.
So I thought I'd
talk a little bit
about how Family has approached
performing and rehearsing
remotely.
Sort of how last
semester went and what
we're doing this semester.
And it's pretty different.
It was really great to hear
the earlier two presentations.
Obviously, the a
capella community at MIT
is really strong.
And they've done lots of
things over the years.
And I've actually,
in my classes,
had quite a few a capella
students learn about recording.
So I was actually
curious to see how
sort of the existing knowledge
within the a capella community
would feed into the ability
to deal with this transition
in doing these remote
recordings, which were
both really super successful.
So congratulations.
And good job on that.
But what we ended up
doing is really different.
And actually, we were
the only ensemble at MIT
that I know of that can kept
our performance schedule exactly
the same as it was before the
transition to being remote
as it was after.
So we were able to do that
because the laptop ensemble
already focuses on
network music performance.
And I guess with that I should
maybe mentioned a little bit
about what the laptop
ensemble is all about,
what a laptop ensemble is.
So we're an ensemble,
a small group.
Generally around six to
seven to eight people
who perform together
using laptops
as our primary sound
source and interface.
Sometimes, we'll
use MIDI controllers
or other kinds of hardware.
But most of the time, all of the
sound that we're working with
is generated on a laptop
and then either sent out
and played through a speaker.
Or when we're
playing remotely, we
would send it out
over Zoom or something
like that or YouTube
streaming for concerts.
So a lot of the focus on
this is, what does a laptop
bring to an ensemble context?
And how do you perform
electronic music together?
And it's not at all
obvious for a lot of people
how that would play out.
Electronic music, the way that
we see it most of the time
is actually a solo or a duo
at the most working together.
We see DJs, we see solo artists.
And this idea of having
an ensemble of people
communicating is not
that common nowadays.
And the neat thing
about it is, it
gives new ways of collaborating
that really are still,
we're in there in the early days
of exploring how this can work.
So before even the switch
to being remote happened,
we were already
doing network music.
We're experimenting with
creating information
on my laptop and sending that
information to your laptop.
And then you can
take that information
and use it to generate music.
And then you can
send your information
to somebody else's laptop.
And they can use that
information to generate music.
And then you're hearing all
of that at the same time.
So I thought maybe I'd play
a couple of videos just
to orient you about what our
normal performance practice is
like.
And then, just play a
couple of videos also
of what happened last semester.
And I can talk about
how that played out
and how we set up the system
to be able to do that.
So that being said,
this is a recap of--
of course, the Zoom
end is blocking me--
of our fall 2019 season.
[ELECTRONIC MUSIC PLAYING]
So one of the things that you're
not seeing in this right now
is that every performer has
their own speaker that's
right next to them.
So the idea is that,
it's just like it
would be in a music ensemble.
When somebody is making
sound, that sound
is coming from that
performer's location.
And when you're in the
room with everyone,
the sound is distributed
according to the ensemble.
So you can tell what
everybody is doing.
And there's really a sense of
spatial identity and spatial
resonance in the room.
And we would do all different
kinds of formations.
We would stand in small circles.
We would sit down on
the floor by the piano.
We would sit amongst
the audience sometimes.
We would go and sit
and stand all the way
around the room
in a giant circle.
And even walk
around a little bit.
So really, we'd play
around with space a lot,
play around with
spatialization a lot,
really concerned with this idea
of sharing musical materials,
things like that.
So when it came time
to move remotely,
we were able to take that same
approach when we went online.
And one of the
reasons why we were
able to do that
so successfully is
that we're already sharing
information over networks.
Right?
That's part of our
normal practice.
So the idea that we would share
information over the internet
remotely across, you know,
across the US and in Taiwan,
it was really easy
for us to do that.
But we did have to create
some new software that
would generate all of the
sound that you would hear.
Everybody's laptop
would basically
generate all of the sounds.
So everybody would
be hearing the sound
from everybody's
sound on their laptop.
And then everybody would
be sending control messages
to everybody else.
It was a giant network of
people sending information
back and forth.
One of the interesting
things about last semester,
too, that was slightly
different is that we
were using a controller.
So this piece, "Cursors,"
is using a launchpad grid
controller as our input device.
And we had a visualization
for this piece where everybody
had control over
one little chunk
of this circular sequence.
And they could control the notes
and placements on the sequence
and interact both
with placing events
and also interact with
this cursor, which
is triggering events.
This is a little bit of
this piece, "Cursors."
[ELECTRONIC MUSIC PLAYING]
So when we perform this,
this is actually a video
that I produced
for an MTA event.
But this is also exactly
how we perform it.
All of these videos
of these performances
were taking place
at the same time.
So this was a real
time performance
in all these
different locations.
We just had everybody
sort of use a webcam
to record their local video.
And then, we edited it together
into a nice presentation.
But we would do the
same thing for concerts.
So this is a concert
that we did over Zoom.
And we actually, the
way we did it is we
would have a big Zoom
room everybody was in.
And then, we were streaming
the audio and the video
from my laptop through
YouTube Studio.
And actually we were streaming
to different people's,
different people would
share their screens.
And we would stream
from one laptop
to YouTube streaming services.
So this is another
concern that we did,
another live concert that
was played synchronously.
[ELECTRONIC MUSIC PLAYING]
And I think we're getting
basically mono sound here.
Zoom does not play very
well with stereo sound.
But one component
that you're missing
is we're also able to
implement a 360 degree spatial
audio algorithm.
So you could actually
hear each person's sound
coming from a different
location in space.
You're not getting that right
now because Zoom does not
support stereo audio
natively, anyway.
So that was something that we
were able to do, like I said,
largely because we
were already working
with network performances.
And it enabled us to translate
that into this virtual setting.
So this semester--
and the reason,
one reason I wanted to
show that last video--
is, this semester, we're
doing entirely online.
Some of the other
semesters at MIT--
sorry, some of the
other ensembles at MIT
are trying to bring in
some synchronous and even
some in-person rehearsal
and performance.
And I decided that, since
working virtually works really
well for us, it's actually
pretty comfortable based
on the way that we work, we
would stay entirely virtual
so everybody has
the same experience.
There's no concern about whether
people are on campus or not.
And we're also exploring
something else, which
is a live coding performance.
So live coding is
this situation where
people are typing code in
real time, executing it,
and then it generates sound.
So just to give you
a quick sense of what
live coding looks like, this
is our live coding environment
we're using.
We're actually
writing code and then
executing it to generate sound.
I'm not getting sound right now.
[FEEDBACK]
Just because it's not
playing nicely with Zoom.
But that's what we're going
to be doing this semester.
So we've got a really different
perspective than SyncopAsian
and Logarhythms and a lot
of the other ensembles
at MIT because this system
is very natural for us.
So maybe I'll wrap
up right there.
I do have a lot of
questions for the other two
presenters and the MIT
community generally.
There are a lot of
really interesting ways
of approaching dealing with
this virtual music performance.
But I'll wrap up my section.
And we can move onto the Q&A
or have a little discussion.
You've just basically
handled my transition for me.
I was about to thank
all of you and suggest
that we move into
some Q&A. If anybody
has any questions, please feel
free to pop them in the chat
or to use the Raise
Hand function.
And I guess I will start about
how you're all planning to--
I mean, Ian touched on
this-- but how is everybody
planning to continue rehearsing
and producing music virtually?
I open up the floor.
For us, our approach is very
similar to this last semester.
So we're going to
continue producing videos
and trying to hold
another concert
at the end of this semester.
I think the main
difference this semester
will be that what we're
actually trying to rehearse.
So of course, there is still not
going to be any audio syncing
through Zoom.
And there are going
to be latency delays.
But what we're trying to do
is just share computer sound,
sing along to ourselves,
kind of emulate
the concept of rehearsal
without the reactiveness.
So that's going to
be one way we're
going to try to enhance
the music learning process,
especially since we're doing all
new arrangements this semester.
Does anyone else going
to say something?
I have some questions, actually.
If anybody has any
interest or time,
I know it's a big subject,
but I'm a musician myself.
And we've been struggling
to come up with ideas
for using low latency programs.
So if anybody has
any ideas about that,
I'd be really curious
to hear about it.
I could probably chime in,
unless somebody else wants to--
Go ahead, go ahead.
So there's a lot
of different ways
that people haven't tried
to do low latency audio.
There's actually
a move right now,
I think it's called a LLAMIT,
Low Latency Audio at MIT.
Professor Aaron [INAUDIBLE]
is another professor
in the Music Tech Department at
MTA, has been organizing this.
So there has been a
community of people
who have been networking
music for a long time.
And they use this tool
called Jack Tripp.
It's an open source, low
latency audio network connection
where you can stream audio
from multiple locations
to other multiple locations.
And you can do this kind
of multi-site real time
performance.
But it's really
challenging to do this
in a way that is effective.
We all know that
Zoom doesn't work.
Right?
And the reason why
is because Zoom
has all this latency, which is
built in to buffer the audio.
And so, Jack Tripp is
trying to implement
a more efficient network
where you can sort
of share audio in real time.
But you're always going to be
limited by a couple of things.
You're limited, first
of all, by the speed
of light, which is
actually not inconsiderable
when you're dealing with
intercontinental audio, which
can add many milliseconds
of a delay to the audio.
And then also, signals
going through the internet.
The internet is not designed for
real time network transmission.
It's designed to buffer.
And it's designed to
get information there
reliably rather than in time.
So dealing with these
things can be really tricky.
I think that what
Aaron has found--
well, if you have a really
robust internet network,
like MIT does, like an
academic university does,
you can leverage that
academic network,
which is going to not have many
of the same latency problems
that commercial
internet will have.
Like our home internet will
have much worse latency
than a university
infrastructure internet.
So if everybody is
at a university,
then using something like Jack
Tripp to do low latency audio
is actually pretty feasible.
And again, mostly feasible
within like a 400 or 500
mile range.
Because once you get out
of the 400 or 500 miles,
the speed of light becomes
a factor in terms of delay.
So that, I think, is
sort of the situation
that's going on with that.
If you're trying to do
low latency audio locally,
it's not impossible.
But also to set these things
up is not technically trivial.
So it takes a lot
of trial and error
and a lot of [INAUDIBLE]
figuring this stuff out.
So possible, but not easy.
Most people aren't doing it.
If it was easy, people would
be doing it all over the place.
And it's hard enough that
most people are not doing it.
Has anybody here had any
experience with that?
I actually just wanted to
tack something onto that.
So I haven't gotten
experience yet.
But I will be, because I am
also part of the Chamber Music
program at Emerson.
So I have been discussing
with the people
there about working with
this low latency technology.
So I've seen a lot of what's
been discussed about it.
And regarding
SyncopAsian specifically,
we've considered the option
of using this low latency
technology.
And we might for just
the occasional jam
session or whatever.
But like Logs mentioned, we
won't be doing rehearsals
in the traditional sense
of singing synchronously.
Because even, if we
get everything optimal,
we have people on the
other side of the planet.
And at a certain point,
low latency solutions
just don't work.
So we're definitely
limited in that sense.
And so, our rehearsals
this semester--
or we're labeling them
more as workshops,
because they're not
going to be rehearsals
in the same usual sense, like
singing together and doing
everything synchronously.
We are still playing to
produce things similar to how
we did this past semester.
But unfortunately,
we still won't
be able to get the same
feel of singing together.
That's great to hear.
I also saw that Ryan
looked like he was trying
to chime in at one point.
So, as we're about
to wrap up, I just
want to make sure that he
has a chance to come in, too.
I mean, most of what
I was going to say
was actually said
by Ian and Justin.
I guess I'll add in
that we did end up
trying a low latency solution
on a program called Jam Kazam.
And it was not feasible with
someone across the country.
I tried doing it with--
I'm based in Virginia.
And I tried doing it with
someone in California.
And the delays were
something like a tenth
of a second, which
is just a non-starter
for simultaneous rehearsal.
I did try it with
a friend in DC.
So he was about 40 miles away.
And it was pretty
acceptable at that point.
So I think, in the
future, especially
if the software is
improved, perhaps
we can't do cross country.
But something if
everyone's in Boston
but we can't meet up in person
due to social distancing
requirements, we could all
rehearse together in a room.
I could see that becoming
a reality at some point.
Although probably not before
the end of this pandemic.
All right.
We are coming up on
the end of the session.
This has been really fantastic.
If anybody has
any parting shots,
I would love to hear them.
But if not, I'd like to
invite you to stick around.
In this room, we'll
have a 15 minute break.
And there are going to be
some slideshows happening
with some information
surrounding all of Arts
on the Radar.
And there's going to
be some nifty trivia
about the arts at MIT.
So if you feel like hanging
out, that would be great.
And if you'd rather get up
stretch, have a drink of water,
or something at
8:00 in this room,
we'll be doing a
roundtable panel
with some of our most actively
engaged student artists at MIT.
And they'll discuss their
experiences engaging with Arts
on Campus and virtually.
And in the other Zoom room,
which we can send information
about on the website,
there is a presentation,
a Maker workshop through ACT--
Arts, Culture, and Technology.
So with that, I bid
you all farewell.
Thank you all so much.
Thanks, everyone.
About all of this great music.
Thank you.
Thank you for having us.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Cutting Across the
Archive, from Photo Montage
to Digital Folklore.
This Advanced
Photography course is
designed for students who wish
to explore photography, images,
and archives as
tools and resources
for artistic practices.
The course focuses on the
use of archival images
and photographic practices
while encouraging students
to explore analog,
digital, and [AUDIO OUT]
and new technologies.
Through lectures,
readings, film screenings,
student-driven projects,
visiting artist presentations,
and critics sessions,
students experiment
with a range of
artistic strategies
while engaging in cross
disciplinary research
and working on collaborative
and individual assignments.
Across a diverse spectrum of
themes and historical context,
students read and
discuss theoretical texts
related to the use of archives
and artistic practices.
Advance Video and Related Media.
This course introduces advanced
strategies of image and sound
manipulation, both
technical and conceptual.
We'll cover everything from
preproduction, planning,
storyboards, and scripting
through the refinement
of digital editing
techniques, visual effects
such as Chroma Key,
post-production,
as well as audio and
sonic components.
Context is provided by regular
viewings of contemporary video
artworks and other
audio visual formats.
Video Installation is a
contemporary and expanding art
genre that intersects with
the worlds of architecture,
engineering, programming,
new media, and performance
practices.
In this intermediate
to advanced course,
students are encouraged to
expand the current themes
and methods within their
art or research practices
by experimenting with
various video installation
strategies, such as video
mapping to 3D objects, site
specific architectural projects,
multi-channel projection
environments,
mixing moving image
content with live performance,
wearable sculptures,
live feeds, physical computing,
or other elements of interest.
[MUSIC PLAYING]